aquí tengo esta serie tengo menos cinco
tercios más veinticinco sextos menos 125
novenos y así seguimos sumando hasta
bueno sin sin detenernos y el detalle
aquí es que tenemos que expresar la
serie que represente esto con el patrón
que estos tres términos nos indica muy
bien así que te invito a que en este
momento hagas una pausa e intentes
escribir esta serie connotación sigma
así que suponiendo que ya hiciste eso
vamos a vamos a ir analizando lo primero
veamos cómo son los términos lo primero
que uno puede notar es este signo que va
oscilando va oscilando entre menos y más
menos y más menos y más muy bien
entonces lo que lo que podemos hacer
para ir capturando este signo que vaya a
alterar alternándose con con el índice
digamos que vamos recorriendo es hacer
lo siguiente poner menos uno y elevarlo
al índice por ejemplo este primer
término es menos 1 a la 1 y nos da menos
este segundo sería menos 1 al cuadrado y
menos 1 al cuadrado nos da más el
tercero sería menos 1 al cubo y que esto
nos vuelve a dar menos entonces los
signos que oscilan lo podemos poner como
menos 1 elevado a nuestro índice la
segunda observación que podemos tener es
que pasa con el numerador si nos fijamos
con el numerador tenemos aquí 5 25 y 125
y estos corresponden a las potencias las
potencias de 5 por ejemplo este es 5 a
la 1 estoy aquí este de acá será 5
elevado a la 2 este de acá será 5
elevado a la 3 muy bien entonces estamos
elevando a la al al índice verdad que
corresponde a ese término y ahora veamos
qué pasa con el denominador
con estos denominadores 3 6 y 9 aquí 3
simplemente lo podemos expresar como 3
por 1
este es 3 por 2 y este es 3 por 3 muy
bien entonces lo que está pasando con el
denominador es que lo estamos
escribiendo como 3 por el índice muy
bien entonces cómo termina de esto de
escribirse tendremos la suma
el signo de suma sigma desde 1 verdad
todo esto va elevado a la 1 por 1
elevado a la 1 empezamos en 1 y nunca
terminamos no seguimos hasta el infinito
de quien de menos 1 a la n por 5 a la n
sobre 3 por n muy bien y esto debe ser
igual a esta serie muy bien entonces lo
que puedes tú puedes verificar que en
efecto se da para cada término por
ejemplo cuando n es 1 tenemos menos 1 a
la 1 que es menos por 5 a la 1 que 5
entre 3 por 1 que es 3 verdad y así tú
puedes verificar cada uno de los
términos sucesivos